el mayor giro político en alemania un
tabú que se remonta a la segunda guerra
mundial se rompe berlín va a invertir
considerablemente en reforzar su
ejército frente al parlament o el cáncer
olaf scholz justificó la medida
debemos apoyar a ucrania en esta
situación desesperada lucha por la
libertad y por su democracia por los
valores que compartimos
el gobierno tomó decisiones radicales
más de 100 mil millones de euros para
modernizar el ejército más del doble del
presupuesto militar del año anterior
otro anuncio de importancia un nuevo
arbitraje presupuestario más de 2% del
pib se invertirá cada año para la
defensa esto va aún más allá del
objetivo de los países de la otan la
entrega de armas a ucrania fue otro tabú
roto por berlín desde 1945 la posición
oficial es la de no entregar armas en
zonas de conflicto un principio
criticado dados los acontecimientos
actuales el sábado el primer ministro
polaco atacó la posición alemana en él
considerando la demasiado pasiva
y martín alemania no puede sumergirse en
un semejante egoísmo esto debe pararse
en lo económico berlín también se mostró
a la ofensiva el país decidió excluir a
ciertos bancos rusos del sistema swift
engranaje clave de la banca
internacional el canciller alemán se
declaró además dispuesto a imponer
nuevas sanciones si fuera necesario